[Music]
yoga
and choke sex i was like do you enjoy
breathing or not
pick up your mind you millennial
i think it's funny that tanner is a
white person's name
[Applause]
[ __ ] you absolutely can you just
gotta ask you should be like hey this is
my mexican friend tanner i'm just like
the bartender's friend
that sounds like
i love the black panther movie because
they gave black children a hero they
could finally look up to
and not just someone like martin king jr
or malcolm x or harriet tubman or
thurgood marshall or george washington
carver ferdinand douglas or nelson
mandela coffee and on
denzel washington tupac baby obama opera
beyonce
now there's a fake person that dressed
like a cat
congratulations what are they gonna come
out with a yellow panda huh what the
[ __ ]
so i am not just the last guy straight
now i am actually a different asian
person
i wasn't in the back just trying to pray
away the gay
i'm actually another person uh i am
asian or as i've known this country i'm
chinese
i'm from a province in china called
south korea
it's right next to japan province and
we're all gonna die now right
a lot of people make fun of asians
because we eat dogs which i understand
can be very shocking
because in america dogs are treated like
family members but in asia
we treat our family members like family
members
this real little tradition we have back
home
where instead of buying an animal we
just love our grandma
would you never want better in asia
unless you're a baby girl which case
would throw you in the river
and everyone else would hear about it
don't let the river
i mean that's the reason why i think
it's so weird that asian women act like
they're such hot [ __ ]
because back home we're throwing them
away
you don't impress me you look like me i
can throw on a wig and be a seven
anyone can [ __ ] white dudes that's easy
i uh i am single i have yet to meet my
soul mate i'm beginning to think maybe
it's her fault she needs to get out more
she seems like a loser
i think i can do better my friends are
like dude you need to learn how to talk
to women
maybe or maybe women should learn to
listen to hans
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
[Music]
it's so intricate this one lady was like
did you know that because i can make a
baby my vagina is technically a 3d
printer
i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer
your vagina is the tray
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
it takes nine months to print and the
whole time is printing is complaining
needless to say i did not send any trays
that night
a lot of women give birth i feel like if
men gave birth we'd be like bro i've
been eating so much protein and creatine
during my pregnancy
this baby's like 27 pounds already bro
check out a six-pack of the ultrasound
it's all about those gains the first
trimester
i um i i i was talking to this dude
who's like we're so lucky we're not gay
can you imagine if most of the gender we
were attracted to wasn't attracted to
his back
and i was like whoa can't even imagine
they must cry a lot a lot of my asian
friends make fun of me because i like to
eat general says chicken
they're like hans isn't general says
chicken's just a shitty americanized
version of something authentically asian
i was like yeah but some i
my favorite movie is rush hour 3.
[Music]
i love rednecks because rednecks can
survive in any wilderness situation that
you put them in
except a situation where everyone has
equal rights
that kind of [ __ ] them up you can limit
a swamp with an alligator why can't you
live in a cul-de-sac with a minority
figure it out
i'm enjoying smiling
i don't understand people who say make
america great again
because that means they hate what we
have now so they want to go back to the
past
but if we go back to the past we're just
gonna get this again
that's the exact recipe for this thing
you hate so much is what we did in the
past
it's like being like i hate this cake
let's go back to the time we mix the
flour with the egg and put it in the
oven
that's my favorite time i'll take a cake
you idiot
you're gonna make another cake um i
uh you know i love white people i think
every white pride is a great thing
uh but i think a lot of people do it
incorrectly they're always into like the
nazis or the confederate flag they're
never into building a castle or yodeling
that's not white pride that's just
racism
you don't have to be white to be racist
i can hate the jews too
i mean i don't understand a lot of
sayings in english they say in prison
don't drop the soap
that's not even helpful it should be
don't pick up the soap
you can drop as much soap as you want as
the bending over where they really get
you
who are these rapists like man i want to
get that kid but he never drops the soap
[Music]
does he have a butthole we'll never know
i guess i don't like that they're
go-getters they don't take no for an
answer
it's not gonna get raped you're just
gonna really clean hands while it
happens
um i am uh yeah so that's just sort of a
little bit about me
i uh i think
capitalism is fine if you want to do it
but just don't make everyone play a
stupid game
i like fortnite i don't make your
grandma play and take away her house if
she loses
i like how americans will say communism
never works
as if we didn't try everything to stop
it from working
as if we didn't spend billions of
dollars and kill millions of people to
make sure it wouldn't work
remember the war in vietnam we're pretty
anxious about it not working
communism never works because whenever
people control the means of production
they're democratically elected leaders
mysteriously die
and a small rebel group always finds
automatic weapons
and look they're hitting themselves
why are you destabilizing yourself why
are you destabilizing yourself why are
you destabilizing yourself
i mean i'm not a communist but i do
support any policies that republicans
consider communism
which is whatever two or more people
gather to do something nice
i was a proud supporter of andrew yang i
was in the yang gang
i guess i guess we'll never get to find
out what
it's like to live in a youngster's
paradise
i was really looking forward to the yang
bang
bang bang bang move for yang
i i think universal basic income is
awesome i think if everyone got one
thousand dollars every month
you guys would be a lot more bearable to
be around
[Music]
here's the money stop playing music on
the subway
i paid for it i mean i think poor people
are disgusting and
i want to get rid of them but give them
a lot of money
do you think people who play bluetooth
speaker music out loud have ever crossed
paths with each other
i saw this youtube video where this guy
was like i used skateboarding to express
my emotions
but i've never needed a skateboard to do
that you know
i've never been arguing with the
girlfriend a bit like you probably have
my skateboard
you show it really will you talk to your
ex i feel like this
that's how i feel um
i uh my name is hans and i live in a
band so i can pursue comedy full time
so if you didn't think i was funny i'm
sorry i'm trying really hard
i know someone's in the back like yeah
that's funny but not living your van
funny
could have written that joke in an
apartment buddy
all right that's one time thank you guys
very much